mass shootings in 2019 are on practice
surpassed the total from 2018 the gun
violence archive counts more than 250
mass shootings so far this year in
America the group defines mass shootings
as any incident where four or more
people are shot not including the gunman
yesterday President Trump proposed
several ideas to curb gun violence
they include passing so-called red flag
laws and addressing mental health
Kevin McKellen and acting Secretary of
Homeland Security joins us for an
interview you'll see only on CBS this
morning he is in Washington good morning
mr. secretary thank you for joining us
good morning Anthony thank you you have
echoed the FBI director and saying that
white supremacist extremist violence is
an increasingly concerning threat is it
now our top domestic terrorist threat
well I think that's the information we
have from the FBI over the last two
years the number of their investigations
are racially motivated and within that
category the majority are white
supremacist extremist motivated so what
is Homeland Security doing to prevent
these kind of attacks so the Department
of Homeland Security focuses on the
prevention preparedness and in creating
response assets and communities that are
ready to deal with these kind of events
our cyber security and infrastructure
security agency does thousands of
trainings a year as well as our US
Secret Service national threat
assessment center they've already
reached 12,000 individuals thousands of
communities around the country talking
about those indicators that could
prevent an attack from happening in the
first place and making sure our
communities are ready you're also
providing active shooter training that's
your responsibility that's correct
that's back to the the sister team they
do active shooter training through their
protective security advisors in cities
all over the country continuously and
we're reaching a number of communities
who are better prepared and I think you
see that and had the effectiveness of
the law enforcement response and a
number of these incidents in April you
announced the Office of targeted
violence and terrorism protection but
the LA Times reported last night that
that you have about a quarter of the
staff and an eighth of the budget that a
similar
Graham did in the Obama administration
is that accurate so what we need to
invest more no question in my first week
is acting secretary and we stood up that
office I've asked Congress for an out of
cycle budget request to help bolster it
and increase our reach and capability
but it doesn't cover the the level and
scope of effort across the Department of
Homeland Security Enterprise as I
mentioned bolsa the US Secret Service
our intelligence an analysis component
our outreach to the state and local
communities is extensive and effective
so how much more do you need well we do
need a better effort to coordinate that
at the headquarters level and that's
what I've directed I'd like to to triple
the staff we have available to address
this and coordinate the intelligence
side of it at the headquarters level as
well as investing in those grants and
efforts that are going to help
communities prepare for these kind of
incidents if this is our top domestic
terrorist threat why aren't we of
responding more aggressively well I
think we are responding aggressively and
the president gave us a very clear call
to action task the Department of Justice
with a number of different steps the
Department of Homeland Security will be
engaged in supporting those efforts I've
also directed a surge of all of our
training and preparedness assets on a
risk basis to communities across the
country about based on what we know
there's another element of DHS a
Homeland Security Advisory Council this
brings in experts from around the
country to help advise us we already set
up a task force earlier this spring on
houses of worship and faith-based
organizations because we've seen them be
targets of white supremacist extremism
too often so we're having our first
event next week on those issues as well
you're also a head of commissioner of
Customs and Border Patrol and I think
you said you had something like 4,000
personnel on me in the El Paso area so
this hit home for you very much so we've
got 4,000 families from DHS in the El
Paso area we did have members of our CBP
team had family members affected and we
actually had one of our leaders a port
director Donna Seaford in the Walmart
during the attack she responded and
provided life-saving assistance to one
of the injured victims and just
tremendously proud of her and her
response
you probably heard mr. secretary that
some of the Hispanic
members of the community in El Paso have
suggested that the the president's
rhetoric has contributed to the
situation do you think the president's
rhetoric in any way has inflamed this
problem well a lot of those Hispanic
members of the community are CBP
employees are board chili agents there
are a majority Hispanic and that those
are our families that's our community
and I think we do a great job protecting
it at the border but also responding to
help state and locals address it in the
interior but do you think rhetoric on a
national scale by a figure of the
president's stature contributes to the
problem I think we've got a
responsibility to call out hate in all
of its forms and white supremacist
extremism is a critical element that
we're trying to address I think the
president was very clear on that
yesterday the we also mentioned Jeff
Pegues had a report earlier not
broadcast about about the problem with
the Internet are you do you believe that
that we have to shut down some of these
sites or is it more efficient
essentially to monitor them to be able
to keep keep an eye on what's going on
so I think that's a really important
point Anthony the the Secret Service
mass attacks in public spaces report has
identified that in almost all of these
incidents there's a threatening or
concerning indicator from the individual
attacker and a lot of that occurs online
so we have to be more effective at
monitoring these sites not only is it
federal government but really as a whole
of community effort and I just want to
tell your viewers if you have a family
member a colleague someone you're
connected with who indicates issues of
concern please tell law enforcement
please tell someone about that because
in nearly all of these cases there is an
indicator before an attack happens both
suspects this past weekend used
high-capacity weapons that they
purchased legally do we need
restrictions on these kind of weapons I
think the president talked about this
issue yesterday he's asked the
Department of Justice to look at
legislation that could be necessary in
these areas but I think we've got to get
better at addressing those early warning
indicators both as a federal family but
also with whole of community efforts
across the country acting secretary
Kevin michaleen and thank you so much
for being with us thank you